Joshua, you're on the air.
>> Yes. Sir, Dr. Wall, thank you for
receiving the call. I am one of your
elite Young associates who is currently
working with someone who recently
started with the Young Deb products.
He's been diagnosed with fourth stage
cancer of the liver. He's currently on
hospice.
He he was told he has leaking veins and
he's concerned about weight loss.
>> I'm sorry. He developed what?
He has four states for the last
>> I got all that concerned about
>> he's concerned about weight loss.
>> Oh, cuz so now he's losing weight that
he doesn't want to lose.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Yeah. It's not uncommon somebody who has
forced cancer um this is a very serious
life-threatening position to be in. Of
course. And so um
basically he's in hospice or is he at
home?
>> He's at home with hospice.
Okay. So, the hospice nurses are coming
to the home once or twice or four times
a day, whatever it is.
Yes, sir.
>> So, basically, uh he can do what he
wants to do here. So, the weight loss
thing, you can actually get we have a
shake called Slender Effect shake. It's
a great protein shake. Throw a couple of
eggs in there. You can do that twice a
day. That's in addition to breakfast and
lunch. And um make it with a heavy
whipping cream. This is how we help
athletes, professional and Olympic and
university athletes gain muscle um and
gain weight for their sports. And um
again, don't make it with water because
it's designed to be a weight loss
product. You make it with water. But you
make it with heavy whipping cream or
half and half and it's going to have
enough calories from the cream and a
half and half or the cream and the heavy
whipping cream and it's going to have
enough fat and calories in there to uh
at least um reduce the weight loss or
eliminate the weight loss. Okay.
>> Now, yes sir.
>> The other thing we want to do is support
his immune system. Support the immune
system. And that means um I would give
this fellow What does he weigh? You
think?
>> 160 lbs.
>> 160. Okay. Is he eating or or is he just
being fed by IVs?
>> He's eating and he's eating a lot of raw
foods from my understanding.
>> Okay. Okay. This is feeding. Uh I would
go ahead Joshua and give him uh start
him out with one healthy brain and heart
pack per month. Okay. divided in half
and if he's comfortable with that half a
dose twice a day for the first month or
two weeks I go ahead and get him two
healthy grained heart packs again is to
support uh the immune system and give
the body what it needs to maximize
genetic potential for maintenance and
repair and support the immune system and
then I would also um get him um what we
call Z radical Z radical Z like zebra
dash in the word radical it's a three
super juices and fucoidon
uh which is a substance that's taken
from a red green algae is if you decline
there's over 850 university studies on
it and because it's the reason the
Japanese give for their having like 50%
less cancer than we have and or 90% more
survivability of cancer than we have.
Okay. And so we have this wonderful
product Z radical. Again, the three
super juices and the fucoidin. And I
would go ahead and have him take two
ounces a day, be two quarts a month.
It's a liquid. 1 oz of breakfast, 1 oz
at dinner time. And again, it's to
support the immune system. And one more
thing, see stage four, you got to get
you got to use a big hammer here because
he's in a very life-threatening
situation. You got to support the immune
system with all guns blazing here. So,
I'd also get two bottles a month of BTT
Beyond Tangerine 2.0 tablets. That's in
addition to the healthy brain and heart
packs. Uh, having them take four of
those twice a day or two at breakfast,
two at lunch, two at dinner, and two at
bedtime. Spread them out if you want to.
Um, and these are designed uh to support
the immune system uh with antioxidant
points. Okay. Uh, the average American
takes in about 1,500 ORAC points. OSV.
It's a measurement of how many free
radicals are neutralized by the
antioxidants in their diet and
supplements of 1500 points. These long
cultures who have 40 times as we do,
they get 100,000 or points.
We only get 1,500.
And so by taking um eight of those um
BTT 2.0 tablets per day, two bottles a
month, that's going to gain up to 200,
excuse me, 320,000 or coins. I take uh
500,000 or coins a day just for
prevention of these sorts of things. And
so uh definitely want to get his or
coins up. And of course, you have to
respect the budget, all that kind of
stuff, but I would use a big hammer
here. Okay.
>> Okay.
All righty. Thank you very much, sir.
>> Okay, Josh. Joshua. All right.
>> Super Greens is a one-of-a-kind blend
that's loaded with hard to find,
nutrient-dense superfoods. We've used
what we've learned from our more than 20
years working with mineral-based
nutrition to create one of the
healthiest plant-based nutritional
products available. Each superfood was
carefully selected so that it
complements and enhances the others,
helping to maximize Supergreen's
nutritional power. Next, we added a
specialized fermentation technique to
increase the bioavailability of each
superfood. Finally, we put in powerful
probiotics and enzymes for added
digestive support to give you jam-packed
nutritional support. Youn Supergreens,
the highly alkalinizing super supplement
that helps balance your body. It's the
superfoodpowered way to get more organic
fruits and veggies in your day, all in
just one scoop. Check with your
Youngevity distributor to learn more.
Cardio beats from Youngevity supports a
healthy cardiovascular system and helps
supply the nutrients your body needs to
support better physical endurance. Your
capacity to last a little longer is
largely based on how well your
cardiovascular system expends oxygen and
circulates blood through your body.
Cardiobeads helps combat the oxidative
stress caused by physical activity by
supplying you with key nutrients that
support your cardiovascular system.
These nutrients have also been shown to
help improve endurance.
Cardio beats starts with organic beets,
a rich source of nitrates to support
healthy blood flow and oxygen transport.
We've added whole foods from highly
bioavailable seaweed and mango fruit,
both known for blood flow support and
antioxidant rich sweet cherries.
Then for even more heart health
benefits, we finished it off with key
amino acids. Take your physical
endurance to the next level with cardio
beets. Talk to your young associate for
more information.